you may remain seated until i tell you
otherwise
then oliver you are here today to be
sentenced for the unlawful killing of
your 74 year old grandfather
david oliver
you were 23
when you carried out the killing and are
now aged 25.
on the 14th of january of this year you
pleaded guilty to manslaughter on the
grounds of diminished responsibility
you were tried and acquitted of murder
by a jury on the 25th of may
the facts upon which i am to sentence
you
are these
your grandfather david
and grandmother susan
married in 1966
they had a biological son together
and then in 1977
they adopted your mother stephanie when
she was aged 10.
stephanie has a history
of severe physical
and mental ill health
and has spent much of her adult life in
hospital
however in 1996 when she was aged 20
she became pregnant by a man called
james
and you were born in 1997.
you had a congenital hearing impediment
your biological father left your mother
shortly after your birth
and your mother formed a relationship
with a man called steve
they had two daughters together
steve was extremely cruel to you
he was physically violent
and you were subjected to a sexualized
environment and introduced to child
pornography at the age of five
you were also sexually assaulted by a
neighbor
when you were 13
your mother videoed steve assaulting you
the police were involved and that
resulted in your mother and steve
separating
you also had a very difficult time at
school due to your deafness and you were
the victim of severe bullying
you were diagnosed with autism at a
young age and went to school for
autistic children but you did not thrive
there
your behavior deteriorated further when
your mother became involved in a
same-sex relationship
you were in and out of care
and irreparably damaged by your early
childhood experiences and by your
learning disabilities
throughout your childhood and adult life
you had a very strong and positive
relationship with your maternal
grandparents
you loved and loved your nan very much
and she loved and still loves you
her evidence at your trial was
compelling
and informative
you clearly displayed many of the
recognized features of autistic spectrum
disorder
and you lacked the ability to show
empathy to others with the exception of
your nan
and to some extent your grandad until
shortly before his death
when you were 15 and 16 you sexually
abused a abused a very young female
child
and in september 2016 you received a
six-year custodial sentence for a number
of offenses including rape and an
offence of
in possession of indecent images of
children
i pause there to record my firm view
as supported by the psychiatric evidence
that the offending in which you were
involved was learned from your own
childhood experiences
and your lack of empathy or
understanding
was exacerbated by and rooted in your
autism
you have no other convictions
however you were on license from that
sentence when you killed your
grandfather
days before you were sent to custody in
2016 your grandfather had a stroke which
left him paralyzed saved for the partial
use of his right side
he was largely bed bound and looked
after by your grandmother supported by
daily carers
while you were serving your sentence you
were the victim of violence at the hands
of other prisoners
you were prescribed medication for your
autism and depression whilst you were in
custody
you were released on license in
september
2019 while you were still in custody
allegations came to light that your
grandfather had himself committed child
sex offenses
both your mother and your uncle
expressed a serious desire and
formed intent to kill your grandfather
and had to be dissuaded by your
grandmother from doing so
from that time your nan lost all respect
for her husband
who'd also been cruel to her and
unfaithful during their marriage
upon your release you were given a flat
about seven miles away from where your
grandparents lived
initially you were very house proud and
you did very well
until the pandemic hit
you later found out about the
allegations of sexual abuse involving
your grandfather
and you told your nan that you could not
love him anymore and that indeed you
hated him
however at that stage you did not
exhibit any violence towards him
nor express any desire to do so
covid hit you very hard
you became obsessive about catching the
virus and behaved in very extreme ways
in order to avoid doing so
you also became paranoid about infecting
your grandparents and avoided contact
with them
your mental health deteriorated as a
result because you were isolated and
separated from your grandmother
on christmas eve 2020 you went to your
grandmother's house and asked her to
help you to commit suicide
by providing for you an overdose of
tablets
you said that you wanted to die in her
arms
she comforted you and she dissuaded you
you stayed at your grandparents house
for christmas but then returned to your
flat on the 27th of december
from that date onwards you would speak
to your nan on the phone three or four
times every hour
on the 6th of january of 2021 you rang
your nan again intent on killing
yourself
she tried to persuade you not to do so
but you called the rspca and asked them
to collect your pet ferret telling the
operator that you were going to commit
suicide
the operator noted that you were
speaking most bizarrely and making very
little sense
that call was recorded and the jury
heard the nature of the things which you
were saying which were psychotic in
nature of particular concern is your
assertion in that call that you've been
looking at child pornography and had
exposed yourself
on that occasion you were taken to
hospital
but due to your autism you did not
understand that you were expected to
stay there
and instead you took a tap taxi to your
nan's house
she wanted you to stay with her but you
went up back to your flat because of
concern for your pet
you were in no fit state to be left
unsupervised
your nan said that by then quotes we all
knew he wasn't well
and tried to get him an appointment
close quotes
on the 14th of january you attempted
suicide again firstly by trying to hang
yourself and then by drinking bath water
contaminated with bleach
you were taken to accident and emergency
but released to the home treatment team
your nan described you on that day as
quotes absolutely tormented
you were only relaxed if you could lie
next to your nan and hold her arm
your medication was increased
and your home treatment team was then
changed from the team which had been
looking after you near your flat to the
one near your grandparents
from the 15th of january you never left
your nan's address again until your
arrest for murder you spent your days
with your nan and continued to speak
about demons who were out to get you
at about this time your mother told you
that she would not have peace until your
grandfather was dead
you also knew by then how unhappy he had
made your grandmother
on the 18th of january you watched a
film with your nan about an abused
orphan and texted your mother about the
effect that film had had upon you
on the morning of the killing the 19th
of january the carers came as usual to
see your grandfather's seat your
grandfather's needs
when they had gone your nan took him a
biscuit and a cup of coffee
that was the last time she saw him alive
she noted that you were jittery and
couldn't rest
you asked to lie down next to her which
you did
however when she got up you then went
downstairs it was about 11 30 or 11 45
that morning
you selected a knife from the kitchen
and you went to your grandfather's room
you then cut his throat repeatedly with
severe force
you stabbed his mouth so that he could
not cry out and his eyes so that he
couldn't look at you as you killed him
he tried in vain to protect himself by
raising his right arm he was utterly
powerless
there were a total of 21 stab wounds to
the face seven to the torso and obvious
defense injuries
he died very quickly of massive blood
loss
following the killing you told your nan
what you had done saying quotes he can't
hurt you anymore nan
you also texted your mother saying
quotes mum i've killed granddad i love
you
your nan called 999 and you sat with her
at one point you went upstairs and sat
on the windowsill i'm satisfied that you
had it in mind to jump to your death but
your nan persuaded you to come in and
you calmly sat with her until the police
arrived
you were entirely cooperative
your nan told the police quotes we all
wanted to kill him close quotes
that was a reference to your granddad
while you were in custody before your
trial there were numerous mental health
assessments which resulted in a
divergence of opinion as to the true
nature and extent of your mental illness
the psychiatrists instructed on your
behalf for your trial
had access to all your records and had
greater expertise in determining the
true position
in the light of the jury's verdict i
propose to proceed on the basis that the
defense experts dr [ __ ] and dr coe
were correct in their diagnosis of
autistic spectrum disorder depression
and adjustment disorder the latter as a
result of finding out about the
allegations of sexual abuse by the
deceased
their view was that your diagnosed
medical conditions substantially
impaired your your ability to form a
rational judgment
you did not think that there was an
alternative to killing your grandad you
did not think about the consequences and
did not have the skills to manage
conflict or to see the bigger picture
due to your obsessional and tunnel
vision on the other hand you did
understand that you were killing your
granddad and had decided to do so
this is a complex sentencing exercise
firstly i have to apply the sentencing
council guideline for this type of
manslaughter
i begin by assessing the level of
responsibility which you retained for
the killing
there are three levels high
medium and
lower i have decided that the level of
responsibility retained by you was
towards the very top of the medium level
range
noting that there is an overlap between
that range and the range for a high
level of retained responsibility
i take that view
because unlike some cases of this kind
you were not psychotic
your autism was defined as significant
but not severe
you made the determined decision to kill
your granddad and you carried out the
killing in a ferocious but controlled
way making conscious decisions to attack
his eyes and mouth knowing that you were
killing him and why you were doing so
the relevance of your mental abnormality
is that which was articulated by the
psychiatrist called on your behalf as i
have set out above
as the author of the pre-sentence report
states quotes because of your past
experiences you did not have the
resilience or skills to cope with these
disclosures
and your emotional well-being plummeted
for all those reasons i take a starting
point for sentence of 24 years
imprisonment
i then have to turn to consider
aggravating factors
they are four
one the vulnerability of your bed-bound
elderly grandfather
two the physical suffering inflicted
upon him
three your previous offending
and four the fact that you were on
license
in relation to mitigation
i firstly point out that your
abnormality of mental functioning has
already been accounted for in the
reduction of the offense from murder to
manslaughter
however there is considerable additional
mitigation in relation to your
upbringing
your experiences as a child
and the fact that other members of your
family to your knowledge wanted and on
two occasions set out to kill your
grandfather due to the unproven
allegations made against him
or further significance is your recent
discovery that he had hurt your beloved
grandmother
in addition it is to your credit that
you have always accepted your guilt and
told the truth about what you did and
why
you have also expressed remorse telling
the probation officer quotes i've just
made it worse made the pain
greater
there was ample evidence that you had
tried to seek help for your mental
health problems and had done well whilst
on license
it is unfortunate that the professionals
did not identify the risk posed by you
remaining in the community and
particularly by placing you with your
grandparents
dr [ __ ] has provided an addendum
report which confirms that a hospital
order is not an option in your case
he describes you as a very damaged man
who will require psychological work in
the longer term
in my view the mitigating factors
balance out the aggravating factors so
that i do not add to the notional term
of 24 years
i then have to consider dangerousness
the probation officer has accurately set
out the relevant considerations and i
agree with her assessment and the
reasons for it in my judgment you do
present a significant risk to the public
occasioned by the commission or further
specified offences
due firstly to your previous serious
offending
secondly the fact that there is evidence
that you have a continuing interest in
illegal pornography
thirdly the suddenness of your
deterioration and fourthly the
seriousness and ferocity of the attack
upon your grandfather
you therefore fit the criteria for a
dendritic dangerous offender
section 285 of the sentencing act 2020
provides that as i have determined you
to me you meet the dangerous criteria i
then have to decide whether the
seriousness of the offence of
manslaughter is such as to justify the
imposition of imprisonment for life
if i do conclude that it does i then
must impose such a sentence
in your case i do consider that the
seriousness of the offence justifies a
life sentence and that is the sentence i
must therefore impose upon you
i have already determined that the
notional determinant term would be 24
years before credit for your plea of
guilty
in my view you deserve full credit for
your plea of guilty which was entered at
the first reasonable opportunity after
you were deemed fit to plead
that plea reduces the notional
determinant term to one of 16 years
in setting the minimum term which you
must serve before you can be considered
for release by the parole board i must
adopt a term which is two-thirds of the
notional determinant term
which in this case gives ten years and
eight months
would you stand up please
the sentence i pass upon you is
therefore one of life imprisonment with
a minimum term of 10 years and eight
months from that term will be deducted
the term you have spent on remand which
is 553 days
that deduction results in a term of nine
years and 63 days those numbers can be
amended administratively if my
calculation is ill incorrect
once you have served that term you will
be entitled to apply for parole
however you will not be released by the
parole board unless they conclude that
you no longer pose a risk to the public
if you are released you will remain
unlicensed for the rest of your life
i impose the appropriate surcharge that
concludes these sentencing remarks and
he may go down thank you